all right so we're in downtown Summerlin
about to take care of some errands today
my bear is going to Sephora wherever she
went oh there she is dancing moves fast
she's all the way down there Sephora is
over there and what's cool about this
place is there's like a little kid
Center come on Mister so we're gonna go
to the climber because this guy loves to
climb huh mister
and there's nothing for two boys
a casino
you see a casino oh yeah that is a
casino oh you got a good eye yeah
there's nothing for two boys to do
inside of a makeup store so we're gonna
go and hang out on the side but today
I'm really excited because we're
actually gonna go outdoor furniture
shopping because our backyard
what's that
the score
I don't know what he's talking about
half the times what
we could go through around here I don't
know what you're saying
yeah so we're gonna explore but mainly
because our Outdoors on our backyard's
almost done so we're gonna start
shopping for outdoor furniture and I'm
really really excited because we want it
to be super chill all the friends who
come over relax hang out enjoy the
mountain views swim take a little dip
cook some barbecue and have a good time
and yes I know I sound old as
because I feel like only old people like
outdoor furniture but
that's the life we live now baby
are you sure you know the right way to
go yeah
damn War we probably blowing up by the
way the weather is freaking amazing
today the weather has been amazing all
year long this is
June almost July
and I'm not being melted to death
I don't know what's going on it's sunny
but it's just a nice warm like what's
like a warm like embracing hug I think
we went the wrong way dude
okay we gotta go this way but it feels
just like a nice oh yeah because the
Apple Store is there so we got to make a
right
but it feels just enough just where it's
like a nice little warm hug for mother
nature we are not sweating
and it feels good so if you guys been
pondering if you want to come to Vegas
this summer this might actually be one
of the best Summers to come because
usually it's hot scorching hot like
especially July August but it's really
nice right now
what kind of dance is that
alone
okay right now we're hiding from Mama
we'll see if she can find us
I don't think she can find this at all
look she found you
yeah let's see if you get to the top
look how tall this climber thing is
there he goes
are you going the right way
is it amazing there you're almost at the
top
made it to the top
sure this thing is pretty tall it's
actually like
how tall this thing is
I'm so glad
I'm so glad you're not scared of heights
like me at that age there's no way I was
going to the top I barely want to go on
the top of that thing right now
so
that is a good thing when you're finding
your mate
make sure you find someone that's
opposite to new because Geo is not
scared of heights so I think that
balanced it out and I'm not scared of
spiders
so we balanced that out yesterday as you
guys saw in our Vlog where taiko's
playing with spiders and Jill's freaking
the F out
is the bathroom
are you serious
poop or pee
poop oh my goodness oh oh he's doing the
dance he's doing the dance all right
that's how it works when you're a dad
it could be a turn of events just like
that
[Music]
what do you mean I thought you had to
poop not gonna jump Okay jump one time
all right okay now let's go find a
bathroom you crazy
okay don't poop on yourself
how was it lucky I was vlogging I was
vlogging I was vlogging his emergency
I don't think it's over here come on we
gotta run
Okay so we've been running all second
floor we got tricked I ran all the way
over there
that's actually not a bathroom even
though it's a bathroom logo it's an
elevator
so we found out that it's down this way
down this Corridor so it is on the
second floor
oh my goodness I hope this guy's a poop
on himself
that'll be the first though
yes you found it good good good
ah
safe
crazy
kids
they don't know when they're about to do
it it just happens I need to go now and
it could be pure proof everything okay I
just hear them screaming
did he pull on the floor no
no okay
it is indeed a very beautiful day look
at this
so peaceful looking
yeah it's peaceful today for mom's down
there by the ladies oh okay okay never
mind yeah but it's uh moms with babies
yeah they'll come here Sunday morning
and then they do exercise with other
moms oh that's funny it's called fit for
moms that's so cool yeah yeah
this guy's not scared of the elevator no
more or escalator
foreign
stop by nectar juice bar
for a little cool me down
unfortunately I'm on a diet prepping for
my first bodybuilding show so I can't
have one um if you want to follow me on
that Journey make sure you go to Barbara
Brigade And subscribe to that both me
and JP are doing the bodybuilding show
together and we're both running the stud
muffins program so if you guys want to
even do the exact same training that
we're doing this is stud muffins program
as delicious as these smoothies look I
cannot have one I'm on a straight
straight diet which one did you get
monkey
the berry first yeah
yeah and then what about yours better
than mine really
yours tastes better than hers I want to
see it no one ever said anything about
just one little you know
okay the berry burst is absolutely
delicious especially when you've been on
a diet you haven't been full in like
three weeks
see about this one
mmm this one's very good too that no one
said about a second double check test
foreign
they're both
absolutely delicious delicious you're
you're you're very correct young man
while you're relaxing look at your left
hand you're very relaxing huh
you're having a good time one thing I do
love about these smoothies though
especially for kids is they usually pack
it with a bunch of other good stuff like
almond milk
spinach like veggies like coconut milk
just a bunch of stuff that like
separately kids kids would never ever
eat but you put them all together in a
delicious thing and we're tricking them
into eating some really nutritious stuff
especially for a growing boy that needs
all the calories what are you saying
especially nectar tastes really natural
it doesn't taste like they add like it's
not like Jamba Juice's okay something
keeps happening here like I just had
this is one ordered but then I'm okay
just keeping a little that keeps
happening that one just went and he
keeps going back to relaxing what the
hands up like that I'm not suspicious at
all what about that suspicious
toothpaste on his cheek
he just found out something
and I'm kind of embarrassed to admit
this but it's real
I just realized they make places really
nice like malls outdoor plazas parks and
stuff like look at the scenery behind me
okay there's like palm trees they play
music
they try to keep everything clean with
Landscaping all that stuff because
families come out on the weekends
just hang out so they want these to be
pleasing to the eye because we went to
go get smoothies came back looked at
some of mom Mama's uh makeup stuff and
there's people still hanging out in the
same place
and I just realized I realized like
people bring like cards out blankets and
all that like there's not a really an
event going on and I'm like oh people
come to just hang out I guess I missed
out on that because my childhood was
either non-stop homework like extra
homework that my mom would give me
outside of school homework like she
would go to the teacher supply store
or chores because I was a single my mom
was a single parent so I was like
washing the car scrubbing the floors
vacuuming cleaning everything and there
was one or the other non-stop so we
never got to hang out as a family
so I never really even got to experience
them all that much until I was like in
junior high in high school I'd hang out
with my friends but by that time you're
still just like testosterone and like
hormone driven you're just thinking
about chicks you know you're not
thinking about how the way things are
built and why it's like pleasing to the
eye but now that I have a kid myself I'm
like
people literally just come
to just like hang out with their family
and they're lounging to have a good time
isn't that cute
it's cute like it's just like I'm sure
everyone has a tough job Monday through
Friday we gotta take the kids to soccer
do this you have extracurricular you
have PTA meetings and then on the
weekend everyone just uh
slows down decompress and just Lounge
it's beautiful to witness that and it's
beautiful to see like taika just meet
random kid boom best friends and they're
playing like that
for like the next 30 minutes because I
remember that
like maybe at a friend's birthday party
every now and then but it almost feels
like nowadays especially like in L.A in
California like everyone's guards are up
because they're so scared kids are going
to get abducted and all that stuff that
like and with covid you know like the
mass restrictions like it just felt like
such a different social environment now
and it's refreshing to see like kids
play the way that I did as a kid it's
awesome
okay Mama I think taika made his pick
he looks comfy that looks comfortable I
like this big umbrella too yeah there's
plans for this but you can get this
anywhere plants plans
comfy though mister
you try it you just try it not really
not really maybe everything's comfy for
a little guy like this yeah look at this
what
whoa is it flammable is it slam tested I
haven't sat down all day feels nice huh
so I think we came just in the nick of
time because they have a ton of outdoor
only like exhibits like this
350 plus new outdoor arrivals at Crate
and Barrel so we're at crane Barrel
right now so we have that like standard
looking one we're trying not to do the
standard like Grandma and Grandpa look
we're trying to stick with that like
modern Chic modern Mediterranean look
although it does look comfy you have a
specific look you're going for well you
said modern Mediterranean okay so more
neutrals might just like naturally
occurring elements yeah like wood
textures teak as they call it teak would
work yeah and then in terms of like the
cushion would be like more on the whites
oh yeah whites I like night whites
yes touch it
yes I told them you can't touch anything
unless he tells me first
get your feet off though you're gonna
mark it up
no oh yes
so mama got a good eye these big old
vases look dope yeah because I don't
want anything like that because that's
super modern where
like that one yeah because it's too
modern but this
yeah it has like a very like Greek
Santorini feel to it yeah me like it
yes that we're good thank you
what's your question
what is a good question Shy Boy
so I'm kind of on the fence so I do like
this style like the way it looks I just
never so I like the way it looks yeah
but it doesn't ever invite me to sit on
it if there's other seating options
really I like the way it's sunken in
because I know I'm gonna be laying back
like I'm sitting in business class or
something so I always think of like like
my mom or like older people all the
people that have a hard time getting in
and out they get stuck so you're seeing
that I'm old now no I'm thinking when
family visits oh are you saying I'm old
no I'm just saying I get in and out
easily yeah no I'm thinking of visit
like oh I see get your wife get your get
your wild son
beautiful picture that's because it's an
advertisement we're supposed to be on
the outside let's go go go go go this
way I mean from the outside looking in
go close my mouth but yeah we have a
little area for a bonfire like I showed
you in our Vlogs so we're thinking about
that interview too I think there's like
maybe
three or four main areas trying to cover
one is the seating area like in the
little patio area the second is the
dining area the outdoor dining and the
third is the bonfire area oh fourth we
have a lounge area next to the pool that
we want to set up like a little Cabana
so four main areas we're trying to plan
got it
is that what you said yes
so this is pretty convenient we're right
at Creighton Barrel kind of got some
inspose the main thing is mopper is
really good at interior design so she
already has kind of like her mood board
and what she's going for set already and
then so we're just kind of going into
the stores to look at the textures the
actual model see how it looks in real
life so I actually don't really know
what's being planned I just saw a
general mood board that Geo showed me it
looked pretty freaking sick I don't know
what that specific items
um but that's what we're just walking on
just confirming like the textures you
know sometimes like things will look
like a cream and you see it in person
it's like gray or a brown that looks
different color and right across the
street is West Elm
which is another furniture store so it's
pretty convenient and that's where they
just went in
me like what I see 15 off outdoor decor
and entertaining 20 off select outdoor
furniture
I know but I have a business
business is that double did you get 20 I
don't know for 20. I will ask that's
good
you want to touch everything okay gentle
don't move the letters around too much
okay okay put that back
um
put it back
in before mama
sees
oh no oh no you just knocked out all
that oh my goodness see why I told you
not to touch anything but I know you're
curious no you're spelling it all wrong
here move I'm gonna put the U in it's
outdoors out
the oven
yeah there you go okay
never saw ever
okay Mama didn't see nothing
Mama didn't see nothing you didn't see
anything huh
this is more of what I was thinking for
like right outside oh where's this comfy
oh look at that cushion yeah
um like right as you open the sliding
door this one maybe there's one that
swiveled oh swivel is nice yeah because
our our um
our backyard it has so much movement
that I think I want to contrast it with
more rectangular pieces yeah so this is
kind of pivot and like look at people
and stuff yeah but I don't know if they
have I don't know if it's here but where
I've been looking at all these stores
but there's one that swivels that I
liked and I don't know if this is just
the color that it comes in there's some
stores that I remember it's only in this
color that I was like oh man so it might
be this but I like that it looks comfy I
like how thick that looks and then I
like this
so I like this table too with these
chairs look at these shirts oh it's like
a fabric
that's nice yeah but it's mesh yeah yeah
I see it so it'll just stay clean all
the time super lightweight yeah so and
if it's like wet it'll dry real fast
exactly
this one's wood yeah I like it
this is nice too
I can't talk good talk go ahead can't
touch those shoes I'm hungry I don't
need some food okay pretend eat don't
drop any
oh don't bring your mouth no
throws it's numb people's hands are on
it over there
all right that's it so my bear is laser
sharp focus on the mood porch she knows
exactly what she wants
um so you already have it like after
seeing the materials and the actual
pieces of the person I guess I figured I
knew it was going to be
like that one that shows
yeah I didn't think anything that big
and that bulky which I like which is a
good thing right which is a good thing
sometimes things come smaller look at
this oh yeah
house yeah because sometimes things come
smaller and then you're like oh man
there's something completely yeah but
that has a press yeah
and that yard's big enough where it
needs a present yeah yeah
and complete
hey monkey man
do you know what we're gonna have for
lunch
not excited about pizza
you're pretending or not why
this is our acting debut yeah
why
your balls upright
your son's about to help you know this
is take two that he requested by the way
I know he loves pizza
don't expose this acting
acting all right it's a win-win
situation for us to eat at CPK because
I've been watching this dynamic duo eat
pizza all week long and I'm just
drooling because as you guys know I'm on
my bodybuilding prep but what I love
about CPK is they actually have a very
calorie friendly
son so even if you look at their menu
all these are by the slice right so this
one's 210 200 230 the Hawaiian one is
only 180. and 180 they have six slices
per pizza so I went on the menu I mean
not the nutrition facts it's 180
calories and 24 carbs 11 grams protein
4.5 per slice so times six that's only
27 grams of fat for the whole pizza but
it's 66 grams of protein for the whole
pizza carbs are kind of negligible at
this point where I'm at in my
bodybuilding prep so I can actually only
eat pizza if it's from CPK and I'm gonna
be an extra good boy and only eat half
so I have uh 30 grams of protein here
and I only have like maybe 13 grams of
fat while I ordered
um a bunch of chicken breasts on the
side so here's my yummy Pizza I get to
have half three slices
wow but hey I ain't complaining I get to
have pizza it's all about balance still
achieving my goals still getting leaner
I'm at like what 182 now
so probably the next week which I'm
gonna break 180s it'll be like a high
170. so I'm doing my thing doing a good
job still having fun and not complaining
wow that's crazy you're gonna be a
skinny boy skinny boy yeah I
your happiness meter is off the charts
through the roof so this is how I trick
myself I go
um
I mean Pizza
yeah
I got
uh
I can't believe we have this every week
I don't have it every week
okay this is awkward it's getting
awkward
okay so now we are at Michael's and the
reason we're at Michael's is because we
have a product shoot
um on Tuesday and I wanted to get some
props because we're coming out with a
Vietnamese coffee protein flavor for
Barbara Brigade you heard it here first
yeah so um behind that we we do product
shots and stuff we do lifestyle photos
and part of that lifestyle full photo I
wanted to do was one kind of get our
customer base who is not or hasn't tried
Vietnamese coffee doesn't know what the
process is kind of introduce them to
that whole lifestyle yeah um so I saw
these even including um our photographer
Justin I don't know if he knows what
Vietnamese coffee is or how it's you
know poured because it is a poor is it a
pour over or a slow drip I don't know
the difference between coffee so it's a
slow drip and it looks like this so this
is part of the treatment so we use um a
project management software
and this is me explaining the creative
Sim so if you go to a restaurant yes
Vietnamese coffee they're going to bring
you like this stuff and you're gonna be
like what am I looking at if you've
never had it so this is traditional
because sometimes it fits like a more
like fast food place like leaves coffee
oh it's already done yeah they already
make it for you this one where it's like
dripping in front of you that's like
tradition so this is condensed milk can
you imagine that condensed milk
delicious sweet sweet deliciousness then
the coffee they grind it they grind the
coffee coffee grounds go in here piping
hot pipe and hot they pour in pipe in
hot water then it slowly starts dripping
and then once it's done dripping then
you move everything over to your ice
yeah causing the ice to melt and then
further diluting your coffee because
this coffee is super concentrated super
strong it has like fart always
messes around that like it tastes like
gasoline because it's just so so so so
so so yeah you need to dilute the ice
cubes yes you wait for this actually
part of the drink that makes it taste
good yeah so you want to fill up the ice
all the way to the top so I'm
introducing this to um our photographer
and this is kind of more of the art
direction in which I'm trying to take it
so we have the cut the Cafe De mon
um condensed milk coffee bean so all of
this is all part of the art direction
that I do want to put in there but I
have to create the elements at the
bottom right like maybe it's not a full
piece of wood it could be something like
this and we just don't know right so
kind of put that in there I have the
cups
um I want to throw in this element just
to kind of give it texture I don't know
what it's going to look like yet because
you know we have to set it up to kind of
see what it is and then just for more
options I have like
this thing too so it has like a what's
the style called not industrial but like
uh rustic rustic yes more of a rustic
Vibe well yeah this is like the process
you have to do for every single product
shot to make our photos come to life so
like Justin got the sickness eye and got
the on the camera and we have to kind of
create the little world per picture like
for our sour gummy we have like sour
gummy worms our strength stack our
homicer punch we have like the Jamaica
flowers and so this one we're trying to
really bring out that Vietnamese like
coffee flavor so when you look at the
picture you go
you gotta taste it and normally he'll do
all of this but um
shorts and stuff just figured you know I
do have a creative eye as well not as
good as his but um I felt like I can
relieve some of his to do stress by
coming and kind of providing some more
um of whatever I think would do well I'm
not married to any of this if he goes
this doesn't work I don't want this then
I'm like okay cool scrap it or we can
tip it for you know a future shoot but I
just figured I would hope and like
bringing in more elements to kind of get
his creative juices flowing so yeah and
then I found these two just in case that
was too dark oh this one's actually
messed up but on this side
so he can like frame it out and then I
don't know add layers to it or whatever
but yeah that's what I was thinking
meanwhile we got a project for taika 2.
type you want to tell us about your
little project you're putting these
things on my on my door so everybody
knows this is my room yeah and then you
get to take these home and color them
what colors are gonna use
a marker oh gold is a nice color yeah
and and that's a predator
he's a Sharpie whoa he's made a design
right there
two of them
pizza is that it makes up for multiple
meals so this guy gets another Happy
Happy Meal
meet the baby baby
meal prep to balance out what I ate for
lunch even though
for lunch wasn't that bad cause I hadn't
balanced out already
but one of these meals is only 430
calories and that was like a teriyaki
chicken bowl so I'm done for the day
as you can see we're wrapping up at home
too Mama's cleaning got the Roomba
moving around we got laundry and
in action so we're gonna wrap up the day
thank you guys for hanging out with us
see you guys tomorrow